Now to a big policy pivot
from Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis that reflects a giant change
in Republican priorities.
DeSantis now says backing
Ukraine is not not a vital U.S.
interest. Look at this.
While the United States has many vital
national interests
becoming further
entangled in a territorial dispute
between Ukraine and Russia, it's
not one of them.
His answer, part of a questionnaire.
The Fox host Tucker
Carlson sent to Republican
presidential hopefuls
or great reporters are back at the table.
Ron DeSantis now says it is not a vital
US interest, and he calls it
a territorial dispute.
Ron DeSantis,
as a member of the House
in the Obama administration,
we in the Congress
have been urging the president,
I've been to provide arms to Ukraine.
They want to fight their good fight.
They're not asking us
to fight it for them.
And the president
has steadfastly refused.
And I think that's a mistake.
So a flip flop.
Why the Tucker tail is wagging the dog.
That's why.
I mean, look at the forum
through which he wanted
to give this information
from a host on Fox News
who has been railing against the U.S.
involvement in Ukraine,
has been supporting
autocrats who are
in and around the region.
And this is a person
who has a large audience
within the Republican electorate.
And so that's why
you see a flip flop there.
What's interesting
is, as
you were talking about that,
Nikki Haley, former U.S.
ambassador to the U.N.,
came out with her answers to that.
I mean, by the way.
Can we just talk about the fact that
it is Tucker Carlson
who is sending questionnaires
to these candidates that says everything,
but she's stuck,
stuck to the more traditional
Republican line,
which is, yes, it is important
to us national interest to stay and help
the Ukrainians.
And so let's go through
some of the different answers
which tell you
we are no longer
living in Ronald Reagan's
Republican Party.
There are still people like
Nikki Haley who voiced that view.
But it's increasingly,
I would say, a minority are,
you know, Donald Trump No.
The question is, is opposing Russia
and Ukraine
a vital American national
strategic interest?
Donald Trump says no,
but it is for Europe,
but not for the United States.
Mike Pence disagrees.
When the United States supports
Ukraine in their fight against Putin.
We follow the Reagan doctrine.
DeSantis again.
He's with Trump
more or less becoming
further entangled
in a territorial dispute
between Ukraine and Russia.
Is not one of them.
Nikki Haley, as you know, says, yes,
the Russian government
is a powerful dictatorship
that makes no secret of its hatred
of America.
And fellow South Carolinian Tim Scott.
Degrading the Russian military
is in our vital national interest.
Even the way the question is framed
in the idea that this is it.
Ron DeSantis wants to makes it
about Russia and Ukraine.
Putin and Zelensky
as opposed to an attack
on a huge democracy in Europe.
Access to Ukrainian, the the breadbasket,
if you will, of Europe.
All that
the economic and agricultural power
that would give him.
And then what about Moldova?
What about the natal countries,
the Eastern European countries
that joined native Natal?
Well,
I think the answer from
a lot of the Republican
presidential Kansas Republican
primary voters would be.
So what about Moldova? Right.
This is a party
that just doesn't really care
about that stuff in the same way,
or at least that's what it looks like
on the surface. Right now.
And I think one of the big questions
about this race, right for years now,
the loudest voices
in the Republican Party have been saying
what we hear from Donald Trump. Right?
That's not our problem.
That's Europe's problem.
It's a territorial dispute
that doesn't concern us.
You know,
I am old enough to remember
when this was a really solidly
hawkish party
and when an underdog
presidential candidate
and John McCain
back in
2008, sort of rose from the dead
as a candidate on the strength of his,
you know, sort of hawkish
policy credentials.
And I do wonder how much there is
some of that vestigial DNA
still in the party
that it
as you ask the question is,
do you want to sort of
go to the wall for Ukraine?
A lot of people
might shy away from that,
but do you support
a strong and assertive America?
Do you support a world that is,
you know,
led by the United States
and not sort of shared
by a couple of different superpowers?
I do think those instincts
are still there.
And the question is,
is there someone in the race
who can play?
He's old enough to remember.
I mean, it wasn't that long ago.
the issue at the Sanders tries
to make
this point, Republicans are trying to say
stand up to China
and sort of never mind Europe,
never mind Putin, never mind Russia.
The question is, can you make that?
Can you sell that argument
or will somebody like McCain
stand up and say
it's a lot more complicated than that.
And everything you do against Russia
and Ukraine has an impact
on the China conversation.
But for that person to break through,
for a Haley
to break through or Pence
to break through or somebody else,
they're walking into the heavy breeze
right now.
This is from our brand new poll.
Is it important
that the Republican nominee believes
the U.S.
should not be involved
in Russia, Ukraine?
36% more than a third of Republicans
say it's essential.
44% say it's important to them.
So add that up.
80% of Republican voters
or potential Republican voters
don't think it's
it's not
important to them, essentially,
that the Republicans agree
with President Biden on this.
And you do see
dampening support
among Republicans on this issue.
But that that is not
the same as what you're
seeing in Congress with in Congress.
This is still where you're describing
it is a minority viewpoint.
I've talked to almost
a dozen lawmakers
recently about this
on both sides of the aisle.
And they still feel strongly
about support for Ukraine.
Now, there is that Ukraine fatigue group
that Matt Gates is leading.
There's roughly a dozen lawmakers
in that in the House
that does not want to provide
further support to Ukraine.
But again,
there's there's only 11 people
who've signed on to that resolution.
As for this questionnaire,
Asa Hutchinson, the former
governor of Arkansas,
was one of those who did not answer it.
But in an interview
over the weekend with USA Today,
he linked China and Ukraine together
and said
he sees this as important
to deterring China from invading Taiwan.
One of my favorite subplots
is the Florida Republican debate.
You have Trump and DeSantis
essentially on the same page
when it comes to Ukraine.
Marco Rubio,
who's not running this time
said on YouTube today
there is a national security interest
in Ukraine.
And he said DeSantis, quote,
doesn't deal with foreign policy
every day as governor.
So we'll poke a little poke there.
We're just getting started
in the Republican race.